and Britain's Guardian reports a British  woman was rescued after falling off a  cruise ship into the Adriatic Sea the 46  year old woman fell off the Norwegian  star cruise ship about 60 miles off  Croatia's coast shortly before midnight  Saturday a Croatian rescue ship found  her swimming yesterday morning not far  from where she was believed to have  fallen photo show her climbing onboard  the rescue ship she's also seen with her  rescuers I was in the water for 10 hours  so these wonderful guys rescued me your  name is okay I am very lucky to be alive  hmm she reportedly said she's saying to  fight the overnight cold in the sea he  is lucky indeed